What will happen if Joe Biden defeats Donald
Trump in November?
And then you get a two and a half or close
to three month transitional period during
which Donald Trump is a very angry lame duck?
That's the first question today in audience
questions.
David, what do you believe the transition
period would look like if Donald Trump loses?
So, first of all, I love the question and
I'm glad to explore it, but let's not get
ahead of ourselves.
We first need to vote and Joe Biden first
needs to win before we have to concern ourselves
with what a transition period would look like.
First of all, in the immediate, I would imagine,
a delayed concession.
I think that if it is very, very close on
election night, Donald Trump will not concede.
And if it is a blowout, Donald Trump may also
not concede under the guise that it's too
obviously fake.
Trump couldn't possibly have lost by so much.
So I think regardless of the results, there's
a good chance Trump does not concede.
Now, just a reminder about concession.
Concession is legally meaningless.
Concession is a formality.
It's done to show good faith, to signal the
beginning of a peaceful transition of power
and its norms and conventions and all that
different stuff.
But the concession, legally speaking, is not
relevant.
It is true, however, that if, for example,
a Republican concedes you may see Republican
secretaries of state who might get much more
involved in challenging results with recounts
or whatever, maybe not do it.
So while legally not significant concessions
can still signal to governors and secretaries
of state around the country, how should you
react and what should you do next?
So Trump will in in all likelihood, it if
it's close.
And it's likely to be close and Trump loses.
Trump will likely say he was cheated or that
it was rigged.
We only have to look at 2016.
Remember, in 2016, Trump won and he still
to this day insists that the results were
false and that it was rigged against him because
losing the popular vote did not sufficient
sufficiently placate Donald Trump's massive
ego.
You will probably see a few Republicans who
would support Trump in claiming that it was
rigged.
But my belief is that most Republicans are
going to largely accept the results.
If indeed Joe Biden wins, then I wouldn't
be surprised if during the transition period
Trump doesn't invite Joe Biden to the White
House.
This is a completely standard thing that's
done.
The Bushes invited the Obamas, the Obamas
invited the Trumps.
I wouldn't be shocked at all to see Donald
Trump break with that convention as well.
But then what really matters about the transitional
period is going to be what does Donald Trump
try to do legislatively and via executive
order and in terms of judges and appointments
and nominations?
And what does he actually get done?
Because a lame duck trump that is furious
that he lost and believes it was rigged or
claims it was rigged is going to be even more
brazen and even more unscrupulous than we've
seen him be.
I would expect a ton of executive orders,
some legal, some not legal.
I would expect pardons that benefit him or
his interests in some direct or indirect way.
And I would expect a scaling up of vicious,
vicious attacks against his political opponents.
If Republicans controlled the House and by
the way, this is why this is so such an important
reason why the midterms mattered so much when
Democrats took the House.
If Republicans controlled the House, you would
have the risk of a lame duck Trump doing Wisconsin
style legislation like when Scott Walker lost
the governorship in Wisconsin.
Republicans in the legislature tried to weaken
the office of the governor for the incoming
Democrat to be able to do much less if Republicans
controlled the House.
And Trump loses in November.
You would likely see the same type of attempts
to limit the power of the office of the presidency.
It's not going to happen because Democrats
took the House in 2018.
In terms of protests and aftermath, in terms
of aftermath, that would include protests
and unrest.
I do think it depends on the margin of victory.
I believe that a huge Biden victory would
set Trump off, but that it would really deflate
the sales of the Magga people.
A narrow victory by Biden will more credibly
let Trump claim it was rigged.
And I would absolutely expect militia types,
patriot types, etc. to come out and protest.
And there could be there could certainly be
violence and unrest.
I do think that Mitch McConnell will keep
his eye on the ball and try to rapidly get
as many judges confirmed as possible during
a transition period for Trump.
McConnell has been effective at doing this
legislation is unlikely again, because you
need the House and the Democratically controlled
House is not going to give.
Any big legislative concessions to a lame
duck Trump that they've just defeated, so
I would expect a very messy November and December.
I would expect lawsuits, maybe recounts.
And I don't think that they will actually
go anywhere if Joe Biden wins over that transition
period.
Media will start to ignore Trump more and
more and focus on who is going to be in Biden's
cabinet, who from the from our allies are
coming back to the United States and saying,
we welcome you.
We are glad that Trump is leaving.
And that will only further enrage Donald Trump
by missing anything.
Let me know.